the indians and the cardinals final game
of this home stand final game of the
two-game series
zach pleisek is on the mound for
cleveland he'll see if he can pitch the
indians to a win he's been pitching very
well since he came back from the injured
list
the 1-1 up the middle
gloved by the shortstop rosario and
ranging to his left and beating it out
dylan carlson getting down the line
swinging and a miss please sack got him
with a good changeup
two outs and yadier molina comes up
dylan carlson in scoring position at
second
the one-two pitch to yada ya molina
hit up the middle base hit into center
and the cardinals grab an early lead
carlson will score yachty comes through
and it's one nothing st louis here in
the top of the first
quang kim the lefty getting the start
for the cardinals today
cleveland by the way against left-handed
pitching this season
226 the average second lowest in major
league baseball behind seattle hitting
219.
the 2-2 pitch and a fly ball
and boehner is going to tie a record
hopefully
all three put outs in his glove paul the
young coming up
along with tommy edmond and matt
carpenter
swinging a miss chase one of the dirt
and play sec
as his second strikeout one down
swing and a mess he came back with a
change up
and he got him for his third strikeout
got him really good inning for zach
policek strikes out the side
one nothing saint louis
[Music]
brandmail reyes will lead it off for the
tribe
high drive deep left field onto the home
run porch and beyond we are tied at one
holy mackerel out of the ballpark
completely
for front meal reyes 18th home run of
the year
and they picked him off throw to second
and out so pick off for
kim dylan carlson who leads it off so
it's the top of the order facing
zach pleesack and the 3-2
lifted in the air deep center gone
dylan carlson home run number 11.
cardinals back on top and it's 2-1
cardinals up 2-1 in the third
runner at first one out please sack a
fire
he absolutely fired a missile the first
and nearly picked off arenado who went
back in
standing do the indians challenged the
call
boy arenado really got surprised and the
indians are challenging the call
headsets are removed and the call at
first safe
so the indians challenged but lost
fun drop down aronado bare hands got him
nolan oronato with another ridiculous
play
there's a couple guys out there that you
don't want to do that with and one of
them is right here
he's got this he's got this in his back
pocket the whole way
hernandez in his last 11 games has a
dozen hits
including three home runs and nine runs
batted in
high drive deep center field vader back
he's out of room it's out of here cesar
hernandez with a two run homer puts the
indians back on top three to two
is 18th home run of the year here's jose
ramirez batting right-handed flight out
his first time up the pitch swung on and
ripped
deep left field gone oh
my did jose ramirez tee off
and the indians now lead the redbirds
four to two
here's fran mill reyes
there's another one fly ball this one is
not coming back
deep into the bullpen back to back jacks
his two home runs have tallied almost
900 feet and the indians now
leading it five to two runner will go
now in a 3-2 pitch
much to the chagrin of police yes i
think he wants to step
off and chase him he brought the ball to
cesar
then he throws him out another zero for
play sack in the tribe they lead it 5-2
middle of the fourth
so a lead off double for the indians and
now austin hedges will step in
here's the pitch and it's swung online
base hit center field
chang headed for third they're going to
wave him around here's bader's throw
chang slides and he scores on his way to
second and in
safely his hedges and another run is up
for the tribe it is now
six to two hernandez tried to get a run
home from third with a high drive
to right field carlson settles under it
hedges will tag
he's headed home the throw is not in
time it was close
but the speed of austin hedges
got the head in there ahead of the tag
by yadi air molina two more runs in for
the indians here
in the fourth inning and their lead is
now 7-2
arenado with a bloop single to center
walked
back in the third
and now arenado hit by the pitch may
have gotten the back arm
of nolan oronato molina is two for two
arnado the runner at first base
goldschmidt began the inning with a
base hit that is crunched
high and deep to left back is harold
ramirez
and he leaps up and makes the catch what
a play by big herald
all the way to the wall and then leaped
up and caught that
just before it hit the wall and robbing
yadier molina of an extra base knock
and that is out number two
nolan arnado will leave this game after
being hit by a pitch on the
right elbow arm
runner goes chance for molina and got
him
his second caught stealing in the series
[Music]
trying to hold up but he went around yes
he did that time no doubt
swing and a miss he struck him out
[Applause]
the 2-2 got him and a strikeout
for andrew miller the 2-2
and got him catches the outside corner
brown ball broken bat style the third
ernie clement
throws them out book it
the indians split the series with st
louis winning convincingly here today by
a final score
of 7-2